I want to share a memory with you this
girl she had one mission in her life
and that was to try to understand the
word around her just looking for
knowledge - for answers not looking for
any prize and I think that that's the
motivation that every research has to
have we have to keep on asking questions
and not be afraid of making mistakes so
if you have passion for some questions
that are extremely important for you you
can't stop it in research you need to
have many different points of views it
doesn't matter what gender you are or
race or anything we all love science we
need different cultures we need men and
women young and old and we need to talk
to each other to solve these big
questions and I think we will do that if
we work together
[Music]
you